it'd be The Showdown of the century but
could the mighty Adam really take on the
Man of Steel Dwayne Johnson faced an
eight-year struggle to bring Black Adam
to the big screen now Johnson's patience
and dedication is paid off in its first
four days at the box office Black Adam
brought in 67 million dollars
domestically becoming the best opening
weekend performance of any movie with
Johnson in the lead role notably the
character Johnson portrays Black Adam is
one of the most powerful in DC Comics of
course the biggest Buzz behind Black
Adam is Superman's brief Cameo at the
very end of the movie it's a match made
in heaven in the comic books both
characters possess superhuman strength
speed hearing healing and stamina but
the movie's tease of a showdown between
soups and mighty Adam has got fans
wondering who will ultimately win when
these two juggernauts come to blows in
the DC EU there's no one on this planet
that can stop me one critical difference
between Superman and Black Adam in the
comics is that Adam can discharge
lightning bolts as projectiles while
engaging his enemies in in battle it
might not ever need to come to that
though because Black Adam has an
immediate Edge over Kalel the mighty
Adam's most significant unique advantage
over the last son of Krypton is that he
is Immortal Superman seems ageless but
Kal-El does grow older albeit at a
prolonged rate due to the sun's effect
on his Kryptonian cells it might take
centuries or even longer but Clark Kent
will eventually succumb to death from
natural causes if a brouhaha between
these two super beings ever escalated
into a fight theoretically Black Adam
could just wait it out until Superman
Keels over from old age
since a millennia long wait does not
make for very good storytelling however
there must be a more immediate
determination of a winner for his part
Superman can put up one heck of a fight
his debut in Action Comics number one
back in 1938 saw Superman able to LEAP 1
8 of a mile with skin that could be
broken by nothing less than a bursting
Shell by contrast the Superman of more
recent days has been seen lifting
quintillions of tons single-handed
flying so fast that time moves backward
and punching holes in the fabric of
reality writers have gone back to the
Superman loses his powers well so many
times that it's become a full-blown
Trope mostly because it's hard to write
a high-stick story when your hero can't
be beaten and that might just be where
Black Adam comes into play while
everybody knows that Superman is
vulnerable to Kryptonite he has another
weakness that people often forget about
magic
in Superman number 14 The Man of Steel
was put under a trance by malevolent
fish people and Superman Vol 2 number 49
a piece of magical Kryptonite strips him
of his powers in Superman number 171 he
outright laments that his
invulnerability can't protect him from a
sorcerer's spell this brings us to Black
Adam Adam has gone through his own
Growing Pains over the years but one
aspect of his personality has remained
solid his powers are magical in nature
did you just catch a rocket they were
given to him by the same wizard who
turned Billy Batson into the world's
Mightiest mortal and they stem from the
abilities of ancient gods sometimes
Greeks sometimes Egyptian but always
very very powerful if Black Adam plans
on defeating Superman he should travel
to Smallville Kansas where kalel's
vessel crash landed on Earth and where
he may find green cake Kryptonite green
K is among the most common and Powerful
iterations of kryptonite because it can
weaken and kill the man of steel with
prolonged exposure if the mighty Adam
wants to take out Superman once and for
all though there's only one shade of
kryptonite he should bother searching
for gold Kryptonite the most formidable
weapon Black Adam or anyone else for
that matter could ever hope to wield
against Kal-El gold Kryptonite will
permanently strip Superman of all his
powers Black Adam will have to get up
close and personal to use it but gold K
is another potential way to Victory with
all the advantages Black Adam has over
the Man of Steel the simple truth
remains Superman is stronger if it comes
down to physical combat the mighty atom
will fall even inferior alternate
versions of Superman have vested Black
Adam in the comic books in Shazam volume
3 number 14 the evil Superboy Prime
easily defeats not only Black Adam but
all the Marvels on his own and that was
the second time Superboy Prime best of
the mighty Adam he also made quick work
of him during the Infinite Crisis
crossover event Ultraman kalel's
alternate darker half from Earth 3 ended
his fisticuffs with Black Adam by
breaking his jaw in Forever Evil number
three and don't think Superman will have
any problem dealing out punishment
against his new foe Cal has abandoned
his morality on multiple occasions to do
what is necessary to save the world and
those he loves an alternate reality
Kalel slaughtered Wonder Woman in 2004's
Superman Batman absolute power and the
Man of Steel wiped out the Joker Black
Canary Green Arrow and even Shazam in
the far-reaching Injustice Saga finally
in Man of Steel the first official
installment of the dceu's Big Screen
Adventures Superman is forced to break
General zod's neck to save a group of
civilians bottom line Superman is not
above killing although Dwayne Johnson
put in a lot of work to get Henry Cavill
back in the game the answer to this
question is simple given the right
conditions Black Adam would best
Superman in a fight funnily enough
however Johnson doesn't necessarily
agree in an interview with Jake's takes
he said we will create Black Adam for
him to be the most powerful and
Unstoppable force on this planet the
most powerful and Unstoppable force in
the entire universe has been on the
sidelines for too long so what's going
to happen when Superman and Black Adam
finally get their Showdown looks like
we'll just have to wait to find out
[Music]